all right so it's a seller's market
right now here in las vegas inventory
has been low amid the pandemic and
demand is high
bianca holman is live at one of the most
luxurious properties for sale here in
las vegas
with more on our real estate market and
a look inside hey bianca good morning
alex you know i heard someone think that
we're inside of a hotel
no we're not i know it looks like it
because everything is immaculate but
i'm joined by the luxury designer
stephanie styles cheers
we are in the paris themed girls room
take a look around look at this
stephanie you designed homes for so many
people what inspired this girls room
because this is a dream
this is actually what we call the girls
wing and we went with a french theme we
have these
beautiful awnings with feather and
crystal details
these awnings also go to the outside
with pink lit trees they each have their
own pinklet tree
we have a coco chanel room and a marie
antoinette room
all beds are custom designed by me along
with canopies
uh there's a beautiful chandelier over
there and when i saw it i was like
i couldn't have designed that any better
this is like perfect how do you come up
with this because this is such a dream
this looks
this home looks better than some hotels
down on the strips for real
that is why you pay me the big dollars
hello she is about her coin
so yeah you you designed for people
you've designed this home yourself so
yes yes this is my passion and i am
fortunate enough that i get to do my
passion
every day yeah this is amazing and
bringing that
vision to life and so do you come in
with you know certain ideas or do you
get the ideas from the the homeowners
like how do you
put everything all together when i see a
home even before it's built i love to
sit with architects and help create and
design the floor plan
because i like to put the furniture in
before the home is actually built to
make sure everything fits correctly
i love to make sure that the windows are
in the right place the doors
and i like things over the top i like
things to wow you
in every single space so
and they definitely have stephanie so
we're going to see some more we got
we're going to see some more of this
home
it's just unbelievable from the wine of
cellar that you all have outdoors the
multiple pools and there's even
courtyards here in the girl's wing
cheers to that cheers dolly cheers send
it back to you guys in the studio